بعيدا عن الصور البراقه التي تسوق عن
اليابان
يرسم قاده البلاد نظره اقل اشراقا بسبب
معضله انخفاض النمو السكاني التي تعد
تحديا اساسيا امام الحكومه رئيس الوزراء
دق ناقوس الخطر وقال ان البلاد على وشك ان
تصبح غير قادره على العمل كمجتمع بسبب
انخفاض وعدل المواليد
بيضاء كده
الاهم عندما نفكر في استدامه اقتصادنا
الاجتماعي وشمليته بسبب الانخفاض السريع
في معدل الموارد في البلاد اذا انخفض عدد
الاطفال المولودين في العام الماضي الى
اقل من 800000 امتنا على وشك ان تصبح عجزه
عن القيام بوظائفها الاجتماعيه
في اليابان العام الماضي كان اقل من
800,000 في السبعينيات كان هذا الرقم اكثر
من مليون شخص
ومنذ 14 عاما يتناقص عدد سكان اليابان
الذي يقدر ب126 مليون سنه ومن المتوقع ان
تفقد البلاد عدد سكانها العالي بحلول عام
تشهد العديد من البلدان الاسيويه تباطئا
في معدلات المواليد بما في ذلك جيران
اليابان مثل الصيني وكوريا الجنوبيه لكن
المشكله حاده بشكل خاص في اليابان حيث
ارتفاع متوسطي العمر في العقود الاخيره
مما يعني ان هناك عدد متزايدا من كبار
السن
[موسيقى]
وفقا لبيانات البنك الدولي فان لدى
اليابان ثاني اعلى نسبه في العالم من حيث
عدد المسنين
انخفاض عدد السكان وشيخوختهم اثار كبيره
في الاقتصاد والامن القومي
تعاهد كشيدا بتعزيز الدعم المالي للعائلات
ومضاعفه الانفاق على البرامج المتعلقه
بالاطفال مؤكدا انه سيجري انشاء وكاله
الحكوميه للتركيز على هذه القضيه في ابريل
نيسان المقبل وحتى الان كان لجهود
المبذوله لتشجيع الناس على انجاب المزيد
من الاطفال تاثير المحدود تكاليف المعيشه
في اليابان مرتفعه وزيادات في الاجور
بطيئه وهي عوامل من بين اخرى تثني الشباب
على الزواج والانجاب